bonjour bertrand pierre louis bonjour
vous n'êtes pas à votre première
candidature à une élection municipale au
gros-morne vous étiez déjà candidat et
il ya six ans qu'est ce qui vous donne
l'envié tenace
j'ai envie de dire d'être maire de cette
ville voilà bien tout premier lieu c'est
ne pas rester immobile sur je suis l'une
l'opposition aujourd'hui et assister au
déclin de la ville jour après jour et je
me dis que si l'idée actuelle n'a pas pu
selon ses dires il lui faut il lui a
fallu six ans pour mettre les projets en
place ces années pour les faire démarrer
je pense je pense qu'ils veulent encore
six ans pour les accomplir donc on n'a
pas de temps à perdre et mon équipe et
moi nous sommes décidés au soir du
premier tour c'est ce qu'on veut qu'on
sera élu insurgés seraient pas allés
pour se mettra au travail mais
rapidement
présentez-nous justement votre écoute
votre équipe quel est le nom de votre
groupe et le long de votre liste et puis
comment vous avez composé voilà alors
ils ont groupe s'appelle unis pour le
gone donc le le terme est clair c'est
vraiment une union ces jeux je peux
prétendre dire que c'est vraiment la
seule union qui existe toujours lieu au
monde
elle est issue de trois listes la mienne
thierry meyssan qui était candidat en
2014 aussi raymond dutil et qui était
candidat en 2014
nous sommes concertés et nous sommes dit
dans cette fois ci on y va ensemble
vraiment d'études n'est pas présente
parce qu'elle vient maintenant à paris
mais on a son soutien sur et tous les
membres de son groupe sont derrière
alors aujourd'hui mon équipe sans âme se
mêlent sans le sou mais le sang est avec
moi très très proche de moi sur la liste
sur la liste obligatoire et je pu rien
faire sans thierry aujourd'hui puis
habité mois de l'appétit gain direct je
pu rien faire sentir et aujourd'hui
parce que c'est quand même quelqu'un qui
a une aura vraie aura sur la ville et y
lit avec moi et nous sommes de concert
une petite confidence 1 et depuis 2004
on devait être ensemble mais bon pour
les problèmes de personnes autour de
nous nous n'avons pas pu conclure ça
comment qualifiez-vous bertrand pierre
louis la situation de la commune du gros
morne
après six ans d'action de gilbert
couturier et son équipe qui a d'ailleurs
changé de visage au fil des jours de
cette mandature qui est sur le point de
s'achever
alors constat négatif très négatif
parce qu'aujourd'hui où je vais dire au
soir de son élection ce que très peu de
temps après il a eu quand même près de 5
des missions jusqu'à 8 ne pas des moines
des adjoints au maire qui démissionne
donc je trouve ça très fort c'est à dire
quoi il a un problème de management
d'euros groupe a regroupé ses équipes
autour de lui et je lui ça ne peut pas
aller et il ya des constats négatifs et
ça entraîne jour après jour des constats
négatifs problèmes d'infrastructures
sportives et autres jeux c'est pour
inciter et l'église le tigre vie
sportive le marché plus bibliothèque la
mda qui est un bâtiment qui est un peu
fragile qu'on n'arrive pas à réparer
mais qu'on utilise je suis surpris
aujourd'hui par exemple je vous parle de
la bibliothèque la biotech a été fermée
pour raisons de sécurité
si vous venez aux gones vous verrez
qu'elle occupés par des jeunes qui sont
en train de faire de la mosaïque donc
ayant un problème là quand même
on peut pas être dire l'utilisation
d'une f10 est facile tueur et en même
temps la propose à deux personnes pour y
travailler donc un problème
du coup quel serait votre priorité si
vous arriviez aux affaires municipales
dans quelques semaines alors ma grande
priorité ça fait sourire mais man
s'abaisser la mission régalienne de mien
c'est la voirie c'est à dire l'éclairage
ce n'est pas aux commandes c'est le
désastre total sur sur le projet du
semaine depuis 2015 jusqu'à douze listes
de fournitures pas magiquement alors le
semaine c'est l'électrification - enfin
voilà deux des cousins sa vérification
voilà les équipements qui pourraient
nous aider même pour l'économie
d'énergie ne serait ce que pour la
climatisation et tout ce qui s'ensuit
on n'a pas peau si vous regardez la
cartographie josette à le regarder il
n'ya aucune place le moment de figure
nulle part de 2015 2019 donc en 2020 at
il dit ils ont essayé de fermer pour
elle est trop tard c'est comme je dis
aime les madiot si aujourd'hui la ville
est en moins d'odeurs d'asphalté diable
coupe et on arrête un petit peu ce
phénomène de chaque chaque élection on
se prépare faire les courses se pressent
à couper l'herbe mais je pense que sap
c'est relatif un planification de
travail
quel enjeu fondamental et essentiel
se joue avec cette élection municipale
et communautaire là pour les habitantes
et les habitants du gros morne
selon elle alors large et communautaires
et porte pas ce que je vais dire
qu'aujourd'hui on sait très bien que
tout est dévolue à cap nord le tourisme
le transport et tout ce qui s'ensuit
donc il faut vraiment que logo monde se
met en place et semer droit dans ses
bottes pour profiter de la mutualisation
aujourd'hui c'est plus de 10 millions
d'excédent que cap nau enregistre
pourquoi parce que les villes n'ont pas
soumis à cap non des projets viables des
projets qu'ils pussent qu'on puisse
commencer à travailler à travailler cet
argent nous serons au pouvoir
cet argent sera utilisé peut-être pas la
totalité mais il n'ya pas que nous dans
le bassin mais cet argent sera utilisé
et on va solliciter cap nord ne serait
ce que pour avoir ce qu'on appelle vous
savez les fameuses machines qu'on
appelle pouf avec les gens auteurs vous
travaillez le nom m'échappe là on a
besoin de ça pour charrier que les
ampoules les nacelles et naïve en
profite même pas de nacelles on a besoin
des pareuses aujourd'hui la commune loue
une et paraissent plus de 400 euros par
jour chez un privé
merci bertrand pierre louis d'avoir
répondu à nos questions dans ce ca ou
caddie spécial municipal réalisé par
rodrigue calixte merci